yo I come to a new Blitz game playing
penny from just Latvia or something
awesome
oh yeah sorry I'm sorry not you guys
white and white and red as well um okay
yeah let's go for the porosity nozzle
again yeah
the name in there vital Whitman okay
Queen d5m this is really funny that this
move is in fact the way to go but um
it's it's pretty free playable for black
okay maybe immediately go of the tree
file if I go Bishop d6 now it's got c4
so bit of a problem okay Castle go first
how to continue here hard to play
without connecting rooks maybe I should
do this Bishop d6 now as possible and
maybe I didn't have strange move why
would you we can use structure like that
okay this an idea and 95 let's let's try
that also Knight f4 possible yeah I
thought I have Knight c3 here maybe I I
don't
maybe I don't it looks it looks risky I
admit it looks risky to take on c3 Queen
takes Queen e2 and then be 5 or so not
sure
okay
probably I need to exchange 53 oh we
should be three might be a problem where
do I go
probably I need to thank the Queen then
yeah Wow what's was not so easy to to
butcher this this position up there's no
it's there's some some tricky way to
play here okay I need to I need to give
up the Queen then what time should I do
this was bad taking three three ticks
you Foyle not right now you want to
still continue a bit at some pieces not
are not so so terrible at the moment you
can play unfolded
yeah it's trying to immediately win this
with the direct attack so yeah
understandable this is just busted there
wasn't so sure that this is really the
way to go but it's probably winning
whatever is playing
I don't want roots II ate to come
simplifying rook T 4 would be 8
something would be able to be good night
C for coming I'm not sure I'm getting
probably yeah it's not justified but I'm
getting optimistic again that maybe I
can can do something here
right c4 he's got Quincy three he wants
to wants to double double on the c4
maybe just take this still not
completely easy how maybe it is okay I
like that
I got this move I got this move yeah it
probably is winning for white I mean but
if I would have a million more
43 okay now you can check out but now
the deep on this is free now shortywood
playbook c6 bad remove Mimi
yeah he really did much to screw it up
but I didn't I didn't didn't manage okay
let's check I mean it was so completely
over but I got so much color to play but
at least it looked it looked tricky
probably it isn't but yeah okay it's
winning him the king is is too open
yeah I was I was computers funny like
plus 24 or something and you know he's
even seeing a meet came I was just
thinking okay it should be over already
but somehow it did it wasn't d2 now
draws a d2 drawers yeah yeah I needed to
play the problem yeah this is the
problem I thought he would play like
every normal person
Luke c6 pinning and winning I need to do
this but this this loses but this was my
pre move and he played rook c7 and now I
can play d2 and ended patrol can check
me quite a lot but it's just that a
perpetual yeah okay I created a game
I've simply blundered the Queen so I
deserve to today I deserve to lose
thanks for watching